[Music]
a
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in way that makes
the snowflakes heads explode let me be
clear before this podcast begins we are
loud loud proud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
him Twitter can go [__]
itself twitch twitch would not let
me put GF in the title if you go to
Twitch and you look at the title of the
episode it's not Elon demands Byer gfy
go [__] it yourself because twitch
wouldn't let me put that in the
title oh my God it's so funny you know a
right-winger would be like this is
ridiculous I can't believe twitch and
they go to Twitter and they'd [__]
have outrage and they get their
right-wingers outraged that twitch was
trying to censor Tony Michaels f
Facebook box him now Twitches censor him
I think it's funny I think it's [__]
funny I think it's hilarious that twitch
has
blocked
gfy out of their title sequence you
cannot you cannot put G [__] yourself
not g [__] yourself but
the the abbreviation of G [__] yourself
gfy in the title on Twitch I don't [__]
I don't know
I I mean maybe there's something that
happened someone said go [__]
yourself but we all know yes big step
fan says even the abbreviation yes they
wouldn't they wouldn't let me stream if
you go look at the stream times it was
streaming on YouTube and it wasn't
streaming on Twitch because I had to
change the title really quick so I just
I put I put off instead
of I don't know I am just trying to
think on my feet fast so that's why the
title looks [__] weird on
Twitch and there is no title on Facebook
CU they [__] banned me from there
too everyone everyone wondering like why
aren't you affiliated with anymore
anyone anymore Tony because they don't
want me to
be what it's just a [__] truth it's
the truth Elon told Bob Iger to go [__]
himself he even said gfy he said it out
loud I'm going to show you the [__]
clip Elon Musk burned down Twitter
yesterday now a lot of people are saying
oh he burn it down a long time ago but
he he basically he basically [__]
pissed on the ashes yesterday um now
it's not just Bob Iger and Disney okay
um let's back up a bit let's back up a
bit let's let me describe to you why
Disney has so much [__] money let me
describe to you why Disney has so much
[__] money it's because Bob
Iger is a [__] corporate animal okay
this guy is no friend to workers he's no
friend to the American working
class but he can milk every single
little [__] penny out of Disney and a
lot of people think oh Disney's in
trouble I heard this [__] last night
when I was talking about Elon Musk
Disney's in trouble because of Bob Iger
I'm like no Bob Iger came back to
[__] to to put Disney back in shape
because he's a corporate piece of [__]
Bob Iger is no friend to [__] to
[__] average working
Americans B Bob Iger is a goddamn
corporate vulture okay he will take
advantage of anyone and step on anyone
to make [__] money it's the reason
why Disney has so [__] much of
it not only are they the creative you
know Powerhouse in this country now
because they own so much of the creative
space in
Hollywood that takes up you know the
immense amount of the box box
office but they have the history with
Walt their
founder but Bob Iger is a corporate
vulture that'll make sure to find milk
any Penny out of a $20
bill this guy is no one to [__] with in
business okay and I I don't know exactly
Disney's budget was for Twitter
advertising but I'm sure it's up into
the 8090 million it's money that Elon
Musk has to have to keep Twitter going
he has to have it that's the [__]
business model
right and of course everyone knows that
Elon Musk red pilled himself and and
that's his description of it not mine he
took a red pill how's that [__] red
pill working out for you Elon where you
decided that you let a bunch of [__]
Nazis on your platform that you'd plate
to [__] right-wingers because you
thought it was about freedom of speech
and it was about your freedom of [__]
consequences and boy don't you know
there's still [__] consequences even
when you own Twitter this is the dumbest
[__] I've ever seen in my [__] life
and I love it I [__] love it I'm here
for it I'm here for the show I want him
to burn this [__] to the ground
if you want to know the honest truth
[__] Burn It To The Ground [__] show
the world what happens when you're such
a [__] whiny little [__] ass [__]
and can't handle consequences of your
[__]
speech I mean this morning twitch won't
let me put G [__] yourself in the title
and I'm not sitting here like oh I can't
believe they're [__] stifling my
speech oh I'm such a [__] oppressed
white man I don't give a [__] if twitch
doesn't want me to put go [__] yourself
in the I think it's
funny it's funny that they won't let you
put put gfy in the title that's
hilarious but they're censoring me it's
their
platform I I have the privilege of
[__] streaming to Twitch I don't own
twitch I don't own it and even if I did
if I invited a bunch of Nazis on Twitch
and invited a bunch of anti-semites
bunch of [__] right-wingers and
whined and cried and bitched and moaned
about how there's consequences for my
speech I I bet it would [__] just be
a dumpster fire and a disaster and it
would just crash into the Earth like
[__] elon's
Rockets what a [__]
dumbass what a [__] dumbass and he
believes his own [__] this is this
is all this trumpism [__] with these
[__] white
fragile Macho mesmo toxic men right
these incel types these [__] Elon
simps this is their [__] skew view
they're looking through a lens of the
world that is not
reality there has let me let me let me
tell you something there has never been
a time never been a
time since the first amendment was
written that there weren't consequences
for your [__]
speech always are there consequences for
your [__] speech
always rather they good consequences
that you view is good or there bad
consequences that you view is bad
there's always consequences for [__] you
say rather you're just some person
posting on Facebook your crazy [__]
memes and telling the world how [__]
crazy you are and by world I mean the
handful of friends that still follow you
on Facebook or if you're Elon Musk and
have millions of followers on Twitter
and you and you [__] you tweet out
anti-semitic [__] and you let Nazis on
your [__] platform you let right-
wiers run rampant on your platform and
then you try to go on an apology tour
act like you like Jewish people when you
go and you countown and and and do a
[__] a nation tour with BB Netanyahu
oh okay that makes us [__] believe
you and then you go on a [__]
interview with Jonathan he literally
called him J he said Jonathan you're my
friend the guy's name is not
Jonathan Elon didn't even know his
[__] name it's Andrew Ross
sorin he called him Jonathan I think he
meant Jonathan Swan so I think I think
he confused Andrew Ross sorin with
Jonathan Swan I'm guessing that's what
happened but he's he's believed his own
[__] that he gets to say and do
whatever he wants without consequence
because he has the First Amendment right
well let me tell you something Elon
maybe you should go back where the [__]
you came from to South Africa and
[__] live off your daddy's little
diamond mind you piece of [__] why in
the [__] why in the [__] does any
[__] white man in this country
idolized this [__] spoonfed little
[__] he's never invented anything hey
hey hey you [__] incel [__] out
there let me give you let me let me let
me give you some [__] truth here he
didn't invent electric cars dummy he
didn't [__] he didn't he didn't
[__] invent anything he
steals all of it all of it he acts like
he made up the blue check
mark he acts like he made that [__] up I
a't been to the blue check mark
[__] yeah okay
okay Elon Musk is a whiny little [__]
[__] just like you little incels that's
why you love him and you idolize him
because he's Rich why in the [__] do
middle class lower class [__] people
in this country act like their heroes
are their Heroes because they got some
money this is the dumbest [__] ever why
why why I was having a conversation with
a friend of mine last
night and and I was asking him this very
thing why do you idolize someone just
because they're rich do you think it
makes the them smart do you think it
makes you smart do you think you'll be
him someday do you want to be
Elon and his response was well I mean
he's not rich and Elite like the
Democrats I'm like what are you talk
what are you talking about he's like
there's a lot of Rich Elite Democrats
and I'm like Democrats number one the
Democratic party and the pro democracy
Coalition not only do they want to eat
the rich and I said that eat the rich
but they want to tax those [__]
into Oblivion and and they want to tax
the [__] churches okay we want to
take it one step further like not just
rich individuals Rich organizations well
rich people that are posing to be rich
religious organizations we'd be a lot
better off in this country if we [__]
tax Millionaires and billionaires in
this country into Oblivion maybe not
millionaires hundreds of millionaires
right we get that confused
sometimes we get the the the scale of
richness confused because a lot of
people really don't understand the
amount of wealth that is billions of
dollars like they just don't quite
fathom it because most of us will never
ever ever ever ever see even a million
dollars at one time right I mean it's
it's just not a thing that's going to
happen in a lot of ours lifetimes and
that's okay that's okay there's nothing
wrong with that honestly I think we're
more humble and we have a better
grounding and I don't know reality when
you're not so [__] you know froed up
by
money but there is quite a disconnect in
this country about how much wealth
actually wealth is this is why Donald
Trump is so scared he's going to lose
$250 million in New York because he
needs that $250 million to pretend that
he's a billionaire that's right he needs
that money to pretend he's a billionaire
because most people don't even [__]
understand how much $250 million is let
alone a billion dollars let alone $ 44
billion doll that Elon paid for
Twitter this is crazy ass [__] folks
crazy [__] now put it in the perspective
of other businesses that Elon has right
he did the same thing that he did
yesterday to Ukraine with with the the
the the space internet what what the
[__] that called what's it called
what's that called the space internet
Skylink is that what it's called Skylink
it sounds like a [__] Terminator [__]
right he's always he's always with the
Terminator [__] starlink not Skylink
starlink sorry sorry you know he's
always getting the stupidest [__]
names just call it just call it the
space internet just call it then
okay but he did the same thing with
Ukraine told them to go [__] themselves
he's gonna do the same thing with
starlink and um and Gaza he's gonna be
like yeah we're gonna do that there and
then he's gonna tell them to go [__]
themselves but can you imagine getting
on one of elon's rockets to go visit the
moon on vacation or some [__] and he's
just like oh yeah you want to come back
here to Earth ah you can go [__]
yourself you go [__] yourself oh all the
people that are burning up in the
[__] Teslas because their batteries
are [__] and they're catching on fire a
you can go [__] yourself you can go [__]
yourself yeah go [__]
yourself I I actually like that attitude
I'm not gonna lie my my [__] phrase
isn't go [__] yourself it's [__] them so
I mean it's like one step further not go
[__] yourself but [__] you [__]
how can I disagree with Elon here I
think Bob Iger should go [__]
himself I think Bob should go [__] bob
Iger go [__] yourself all the rich
[__] Elon anyone who pretends
to be rich [__] [__]
Trump Jeff Bezos all of you go [__]
yourself that's what [__] him means [__]
him [__] him [__] [__] them [__] them I
don't get I I I could give a [__] less
why do we care about these [__]
people why do we care about Elon and Bob
Iger trading
wealth think about it that's what this
beef is about that's why elon's saying
you're blackmailing me Bob by
threatening not to advertise with me
because these people get in rooms and
they talk about how they're going to
trade their money with each
other
and we're supposed to sit here and feel
sorry we're supposed to sit here and
feel sorry for Elon Musk and you dumb
[__] out there that s for him
that love him that think he's a genius
he's the smartest person on the [__]
planet we're supposed to feel sorry for
him get the [__] out of here with that
[__] I am so glad to watch these
people eat each other [__] them let the
rich Eat the Rich Don't Eat the Rich let
the rich eat the [__] Rich baby how
[__] good would that be yeah we don't
got to eat them we just got to sit back
and watch them eat each other [__] [__]
we can sell tickets and [__] [__]
Ticket Master could make a shitload of
money we'll let [__] Rich
[__] eat those Rich
[__] why not [__] them [__]
them [__] them [__] them go [__]
yourself Elon go [__] yourself Bob go
[__] yourselves you [__] pieces of
trash and we wonder what the [__]
wrong with this country we stand around
act acting like it's [__] gay
marriage and women's having health care
and [__] get the [__] out of
here it's these [__] who have
been trading their wealth to each other
without including us the people who
[__] produce the [__] in this country
who do you who the [__] do you think
makes Bob Iger and Disney [__] money
you think it's Bob [__] no it's the
people who work for Disney it's the
[__] people out there that are
[__] creating things that work with
their hands and the computers to make
these [__] movies have you ever went
to a Goddamn Marvel movie I just went to
a Goddamn Marvel movie I just went to
one a couple [__] weeks ago I gave
Bob my
money but more importantly I gave all
those people at the end of the [__]
movie those [__] credits those
[__] I mean you got to sit and watch
a [__] Marvel movie credits I don't
know if you know that you got you got to
[__] watch this [__]
you can't not watch you got to know what
the [__] going on to end credit scenes
and all that
[__] so you end up got you got to see
every [__] that was involved in
making of the movie and I don't know if
you've watched the credits of a movie
and how many [__] are involved
in making a movie but Bob's name ain't
the only one there
[__] it ain't the only one there
and Elon you piece of [__] if you think
you would be anything without people
tweeting on your platform you're a dumb
son of a
[__] you're a stupid
[__] oh someone says I'm
whining like like someone said I know I
don't know if you're joking or not
because Tony whining yeah this is me
whining this is me whining see that's
the difference that's the difference
that's why a lot of people like to come
watch this show because this isn't me
whining this this isn't me whining about
[__] this is me pointing out the [__]
truth and pointing it out in a way that
a lot of people think about this [__]
they just don't say it out loud or can
say it out loud because they got jobs
and [__] you know they don't want to be
[__] banned they don't want to be
censored I don't give a [__] [__] him
I'll say
it the reason why Elon Musk is pissed
and the reason why he says Bob Iger is
blackmailing him because Elon feels like
there's a contract between Rich
[__]
that rich [__] give other Rich
[__] their money and they cut
us out of the [__]
deal us average [__] Americans the
people who [__] make these people
[__]
Rich who do you think builds his [__]
cars who do you think puts together
[__] Tesla's batteries and their
solar panels who the [__] do you think
makes those goddamn rockets that he
shoots into the air so they can self
struck or whatever the [__] you call it
huh you think elon's doing all that [__]
himself get the [__] out of here with
that
[__] and then this [__] buys
Twitter and decimates its
Workforce puts thousands of people out
of
work because he doesn't know how to
[__] make money [__] you [__] you
[__] you [__] you [__] you you can't go
[__] yourself Bob Iger too the same with
every other CEO in this country you can
go [__] yourself too go [__]
yourself every single last one of you
rich [__] go [__]
yourself I don't care how you got the
money I don't care if you cheated for it
or you did the right thing for it we
should tax the [__] out of you we should
let the rich Eat the Rich I'm tired of
these [__] going on stage
fighting each other and I hope I hope I
hope Bob Iger eats Elon Musk and Elon
Musk eats Bob Iger good [__] him [__]
him [__] him [__] him
and if you don't see that in this if you
don't see that in this is exactly what
Elon Musk was talking about when he
talked about blackmail because he said
the word
blackmail because I almost [__]
bet that Elon Musk has Bob iger's number
in his [__] phone and I almost bet
that Bob Iger has elon's number in his
[__] phone and I bet those
[__] talk about how they want
to trade each other wealth
trade each other
wealth and cut the rest of the
[__]
out and if you don't know that that's
what's going on and that's what elon's
talking about of course he doesn't say
it out loud quite that way but that's
what the [__] he's talking
about tax the rich Eat the Rich let the
eat Rich Eat the Rich tax the [__]
churches too [__]
them [__] them
that's
it and I know I know it feels like oh
well that's not that big of a deal why
is this your lead
story well number one he absolutely
destroyed any chance he's got with any
corporate advertising
yesterday because Elon Musk gave away
the game and he gave away the game and
he [__] outed all the rich
[__] that give him all kinds of
money that keeps him going that keeps
him rich because the rich got to keep
the rich rich right until they can't
anymore until Elon starts tweeting out
anti-semitic [__] he starts letting
Nazis on his platform and it's untenable
they can't be seen advertising in
between a bunch of [__] Hitler
tweets can't do
it it doesn't please their customer base
nor is it advertising to their customer
base at that point anyways why the [__]
would Disney want to advertise to a
bunch of
Nazis there's Nazis outside Disney World
who are disantis supporters
[__] protesting Disney for all the
wrong [__] reasons like there's
plenty of good reasons to protest Disney
folks plenty of
reasons there's plenty of reasons to
consider not buying their movie tickets
even though I I I make that
consideration but I do it
anyways because I feel like I'm
supporting the people who make that
movie I know it's I know it it's a tough
it's a tough gray area right it's a
really tough gray area that we live in
this
country because a lot of us in this
country our our livelihoods our families
rely on these rich [__] trading
money and keeping their
businesses Mountains full of money so we
can get our little crumbs you know what
I mean our little crumbs
cuz that's what it is they just throw
out the
crumbs they get the whole goddamn bread
cart the whole thing and they own all
the Bread
cards they own all the [__] bread
carts and they ain't going to share with
us and when someone like Elon points out
that hey you're not giving me bread off
your bread
cart so I'm not I'm I'm going to call it
out I'm going to I'm going to show the
world that that you got a bread that
you're not
sharing it's GNA piss him off elon's
[__] here I mean we know Twitter was
[__] for a long time
but here we
are and twitch won't let me that's
hilarious is that not [__] funny
that's [__]
hilarious I I wonder if they would let
me put go [__]
yourself you know what I mean go go [__]
yourself
but gfy they wouldn't let me put
gfy I I don't know go ask
them some other news um some people are
pointing out hin and Kissinger died
oh so sad oh
man I'm so
sad I wonder if Henry Kissinger and
rushin ball are gonna have a date in
Hell
tonight maybe uh also there's news um
George Santos is maybe going to get
expelled again and George Santos I'll
tell you what I'm going to show you a
video George Santos I I'm going to tell
you what I don't know who put this
[__] little nugget in his little step
here but this is why I said the other
day that people should just leave this
George Santos thing
alone because he's gonna cause all kinds
of hell and wreak all kinds of Havoc
he's he's not only threatening to out a
bunch of people in Washington out them I
don't know what that means exactly I
don't I don't know if he knows what that
means but he's also now he's going to
introduce articles of expulsion for
Jamal Bowman because he pulled a fire
alarm remember that he plad guilty to a
misdemeanor to pull a fire alarm in a
separate building from the capital
they're saying it's because he wanted to
obstruct the official proceeding so now
he wants to put a motion forward to
expel him which hey you know what I'm
gonna be honest with you hey you 14th
Amendment Amendment people I like Jamal
Bowman I think Jamal bman is a good
Democrat to have on the fight but you
people out there that are pushing for
like the 14th Amendment and all that
[__] you got to agree with George Santos
on this you you [__] you you
[__] better agree with George
Santos on this that's see you put
yourselves in these situations where you
gotta agree with these scummy
[__] you got to put yourself in
these that's why I don't put myself in
that situation I don't do that kind of
[__] I don't do that kind of [__] I look
at I look at the principles and the
institution of democracy and I look at
the foundation of it and I go based on
that that's where my views come from
that's where my opinions come from
that's where I think we should be based
in the pro-democracy Coalition not all
this [__] stupid little [__] you
know little little [__] glittery
things oh the 14th Amendment and this
over here and let's expel George Santos
and oh George Santos is a liar as if we
all Republicans aren't [__]
Liars you guys you guys just get
distracted by all kinds of [__] and I'm
trying I've been trying to tell you what
what what you need to pay attention to
and why you need to pay attention why
it's so important to create a national
narrative a national narrative that is
based in the foundation of
democracy based in the foundation
democracy because when you get off track
and you start [__] oh hey there's a
motion there's a motion in Florida oh
there's a motion in DC did you see this
motion on Trump oh my god let's do 12
videos on this one motion of trump when
you get distracted by that [__] you get
distracted about about what is
real and what's going to be taken away
from
you cuz CU I'm I'm going to tell you
this George Santos doing what he's doing
I'm telling you I'm telling you some of
you [__] out there that agree
with this 14th Amendment [__] got to
agree with George Santos on this because
if they're gonna expel George Santos for
doing what he did boy they better expel
Jamal Bowman I don't want him to I don't
want him
to but he makes he makes a pretty damn
good case and the reason why is because
people people are losing focus you're
losing [__] you're you're losing
focus like the [__] committees lose
focus right I come here every day and I
point out how the hunter Biden [__]
dick committees can't can't even [__]
put a narrative together they can't even
string [__] two sentences together
they can't even make sense half the
time they can't even make sense half the
time because they get they get
distracted by these little shiny things
and they distract their base with these
little shiny
things and you get distracted by shiny
things you start you start to lose focus
on what f is real [__] important real
[__]
important and that's why you come
here every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on
YouTube sometimes on Twitch depending on
the title and then never on Facebook
because they [__] hate my guts and
they ban the [__] out of
me oh my God freedom of [__] speech
you got it right here with d Tony
Michaels podcast more freedom of speech
right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you numb and alone after
storming the capital have you you been
left out in the cold after stealing
Nancy pel's mail do you feel exposed to
a government that doesn't share your
patriotic values if any of these
describe you then you're in luck hi I'm
Paul gosar and thanks to my new product
paron blanket I've got you covered paron
blanket specifically Works to make you
feel safe and cozy after your
involvement on January 6th and if you're
one of the other members of Congress who
also helped with the attempted coup hard
and blanket will protect you too hard
and blanket is made of a sort of soft
fleece and a layer of sheep's wool and
they're 100% made in the USA don't delay
and get your pardon blanket today for
just
$99.99 actual pardon is not
guaranteed jumping back into it this is
the Tony Michaels
podcast oh I got a couple comments on I
want to address here you guys are the
smartest [__] audience in the world
you know that oh my
God this why I love every single last
one of you even the ones who disagree
with me or descent with me you know I
I'm here for The Descent I love it I
like trolls even if you're not a troll
and you're descenting even if you're a
regular listener and you're descenting
or you disagree with me and you put it
in the chat I am happy that you're
here um um here's one from YouTube
dawned on me says Tony I think we can
you can chew gum and walk at the same
time I'm not saying you can't I'm not
saying you can't there's a lot of people
who can't
though that's just the [__] truth
there's a lot of people that get heavily
distracted um one instance is MSNBC CNN
all these news organizations are
covering Gaza front to back every
[__] day I mean it's it's 48 minutes
of their hour every single [__] hour
and people can't stop talking about it
on social media because it's not real
life stuff here
it's it's
not the only real life stuff that's
happening is the [__] that they're
stoking for for anti-semitic
views and islamophobia like that's the
only thing that's that's leaking into
real life here is the [__] hatred and
the
violence because we lose focus of what
it truly is
about we lose [__]
Focus because we got this internet
machine and we got the boob tube and it
tells us all this
[__] and the media telling you what you
want what they want you to
hear because I I I'm telling you the
media is trying to spin a
narrative I don't care if it's the
right-wing media the mainstream media
the liberal media they're trying to
spend a narrative I'm the liberal
media I'm liberal media folks I'm not
mainstream I'm independent and I'm
liberal I don't give a [__] what you
want to to say how you want to say it
where you want to say it I don't give a
[__] you say oh you cuss too much you do
this you don't do this you don't cover
this right Tony doesn't give us the
facts Tony does this Tony does that blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah I'm the
actual liberal
media I'm the one that reports on what
the hell is going on out there through
the prism
the the perspective of
liberalism that's that's what I that's
what I do and that's the narrative that
I try to spin right because a lot of
people accuse me of that yes yes I'm I'm
spinning it every [__] time that's
how it
works
duh but most people don't realize that
most people don't [__] know
that yes most people don't understand
what is happening when they're watching
something when they're believing
something or not believing
something when they're getting fed a
certain amount of you know
here's an example new polls come out
show that Joe Biden's ahead do you think
the media is going to is going to focus
on how Joe Biden's ahead or they're
going to focus on now how the polls are
[__] what do you think it's going to be
do you think they're going to tell you
how the polls are wrong now because Joe
Biden's ahead well the polls haven't
said this the polls the polls the polls
the polls the polls that we had the
polls all all the polls the polls polls
polls so I agreed Don on me a lot of
people can chew gum and walk at the same
time unfortunately a lot of Americans
can't and I'm not saying Americans are
dumb that's not what I'm saying I'm
saying they're
ignorant that's what I'm saying there's
a difference between dumb stupid and
ignorance I'm ignorant of a lot of
things I I'll admit I don't know a lot
about Reproductive Rights or re or
reproductive Health Care
I don't I don't I'm ignorant of it
that's why I say it should be left up to
a [__] doctor and a goddamn woman to
decide in that doctor's office because
I'm ignorant of it most these old
wrinkly white ball sacks trying to tell
women what they can and can't do with
their [__] bodies and their health
care where they can go to the doctor
where they
can't what's Healthcare and what's
not most these [__] are
ignorant of the facts because they just
don't [__] know nor do they care to
know now when you're ignorant you can
listen right use your little thinky
space to listen to someone who isn't
ignorant and maybe you'll you'll Tamp
down some of your ignorance but that's
the trouble that we have here dawned on
me because I'm not picking on you I'm
I'm glad you put this comment up because
I agree with you a lot of [__] folks
can chew G and walk at the same time a
lot of people can focus on several
different things most can't most can't
most don't have the time they got two
[__] jobs they got kids they got to
take them to the school they got [__]
bills to pay they got [__] debt they
gotta worry
about they got retirement that they're
trying to stack away they hate their
[__] job actually they hate both
their [__]
jobs because their jobs probably treat
them like [__] and don't pay them what
they're [__] worth
so no they they ain't got time to
[__] chew gum and walk they ain't got
time
so that's the problem that's what I'm
trying to that's what I'm trying to
point out here here's another one uh
someone's saying whoa Jamal's calling
out the corrupt Republicans what did I
miss no no Jamal Bowman's a good
Congress person I want Jamal Bowman to
stay in
congress Jamal small Bowman stupidly
pulled a fire
alarm he thought it would distract or
some [__] really
stupid he [__] pled guilty to a
misdemeanor for doing
it now because of that stupid act that
Jamal Bowman did because people want to
expel George Santos who is not convicted
he's just indicted now we know we all
know he's a piece of shitty line sack of
trash and we all know that half the [__]
that they're saying has to be true if
not all of it we know that but he's not
convicted yet that's what a lot of the
Democrats the the [__] case that
they're making when they're voting
against his expulsion he said hey you
can't really can't really do this
[__] I mean if we do it for him we're
gonna have to do it for Jamal
Bowman use your [__] thinky space
that's like the 14th Amendment thing and
I know people get mad that I attack
Glenn I get it I understand that you're
pissed off because a lot of you like
Glenn I'm not saying I don't like Glenn
I just think his commentary through his
perspective lately is
boneheaded it's not steeped in the
foundation of democracy it's
not it's not it's the same stupid [__]
that George Santos is
doing when he's saying I'm going to if
you're going to expel me then I'm going
to I'm going to bring a motion to expel
Jamal
Bowman which in reality if you think
about it I hate to agree with George
Santos but he's not wrong with that
logic it's dumb logic I think it's
really [__] stupid logic that's what
I'm trying to say I've been telling you
for a long time don't get rid of George
Santos for crying out
loud he makes he makes Republicans lying
rep Republicans an easy
target that's all I'm
saying uh someone on Twitch ask kellard
75 ask how long are you banned from
Facebook I don't know 120 days 90 days
[__] I don't know
forever I mean even even when I get off
my ban from live streaming to Facebook
I'm sure it won't be long and they'll
ban me
again I don't
know ask me if I give a [__] a lot of
people are worried that I'm banned from
Facebook
but everyone who wants to watch a show
has either come to Twitch or YouTube and
I know you guys don't like those chats
you'd rather be over on Facebook but I'm
not banned from Facebook I'm just banned
from live streaming on
Facebook eventually they'll probably ban
me what are you gonna
do you got a choice you can either have
Diet Tony or
Tony either way so if you're going to
get Tony I'm G to get banned and some
[__] places that's going to happen
I'm going to get censored oh I'm
censored they're censoring me like
they're they're not going to let me
[__] post
[__] so you can either we can either do
it two ways two ways we can do this you
can either do diet
Tony or you can do fullon [__] Tony
Michaels and I I
I I would prefer the full on Tony
Michaels because I like to be authentic
I like to come here and say the [__]
that I really feel that's what I
like because I I feel like the audience
relates better and people hear what I'm
trying to [__] say better when I'm
being truly authentic that I'm not
bullshitting
you right like some some of these
commentators [__] you and they they
feed you full a bunch of [__] and
they change their positions they're not
willing to defend their
positions they're they just they they
don't have any kind of [__] principle
in what they're
saying and that's why today you're going
to be mad at me because I'm agreeing
with George Santos when if you use the
logic that you should expel George
Santos then you should use that same
logic to expel Jamal Bowman it's what
I'm telling you about the 14th Amendment
[__] you got to stop you gotta you got
to stop picking and choosing what the
[__] your principles are for and aren't
for that's what [__] Republicans do
folks [__] Republicans do that
hypocritical
[__] where they want one [__] way
for me and another way for you [__] that
[__] [__] that
[__] Kell art 75 says you are wrong I
don't know I don't know if you're saying
I'm wrong or somethingone in chat's
wrong I don't
know but I welcome desent here so how am
I wrong if it's if it's me I'm wrong
tell
me um here's Chrissy says plus Tony you
have the First Amendment right right but
my First Amendment right doesn't extend
to YouTube twitch or Facebook it
doesn't when right Wingers tell say that
[__] they're way off there that's the
dumbest [__] that's why elon's like oh
you're blackmailing me with your [__]
advertising dollars no they're not
they're not going to pay to have their
ads placed into a bunch of Nazi threads
okay they're not blackmailing you you're
making stupid decision which is making
them not give you their
money that's what's happening they're
not blackmailing you if you don't change
Twitter to get the Nazis off of it
they're not GNA give you
money
okay I mean can you imagine if Walmart
all of a sudden just let their employees
wear Nazi uniforms while they were
checking people out think about
this if Walmart was like well these
employees they think this way this is
their opinion they want to wear the Nazi
SS uniforms they want to H Hitler when
they're checking people out at the
register who are we to stop them oh my
God who are we to stop them this is
their
right it's not their right it's not it's
Walmart's right to [__] fight
them yes that's how it
works does it suck sometimes sometimes
it sucks because sometimes it's not so
avert as a bunch of [__] Nazis
sometimes it goes the other way it
injures people as it were you know maybe
maybe there's a pregnant woman who can't
stand to check out but they don't give a
[__] they're going to make her check out
right or maybe it's a bunch of Nazis
want to dress up in SS uniforms to check
people out at Walmart how do you think
that's going to fly huh how do you think
that would
fly Walmart's all over the country
letting right Wingers comeing to work in
Nazi SS uniforms checking out people in
Highland Hitler at the checkout
register that's what elon's doing that's
what he's doing when he's allowing these
[__] [__] on his
website that's what he's doing
people would stop going to [__]
Walmart people would be a little [__]
be like what the [__] is going on with
Walmart you don't have the First
Amendment right always you
don't you don't and if you come in to
work to Walmart in a Nazi SS uniform and
you're checking people out their
groceries and you're holling Hitler I
would bet they fire you and that's
probably a consequence of trying to use
your First Amendment right [__]
boneheaded right you're like Tony that's
the dumbest thing I've ever heard of
that's what that's what elon's
doing these people aren't aren't you
know covertly being right- wiers they're
[__]
Nazis what do you want from me either
have the principle or don't right I
actually believe in the First Amendment
the problem that most people have with
my interpretation of it is I'm
interpreting
it correctly I think I mean it's my
opinion again you either want authentic
Tony or you want [__] diet Tony what
whatever way you want it
right but you don't have the First
Amendment right to go I don't I don't
have the first M right to go spray paint
[__] Walmart on the side of one of their
stores
I mean [__] Walmart for sure I I ain't
hate that [__]
place but you do have the right to spray
paint a sign [__] Walmart and go hold
that sign up on a public sidewalk within
looking distance of a Walmart you yeah
that
right hell the employee that doesn't
have the right to check out the
groceries and how Hitler while he's
wearing his SS uniform he doesn't have
that right to check out groceries there
but can go stand on the public sidewalk
on the corner it probably ain't going to
go well for him there's probably going
to be consequences up there too but one
of the consequences is not being fired
from
Walmart well it might be if he works
there but you get my drift right we
don't have just this
total freedom of speech that's just
wrong that's not even close to what
freedom of speech is and that's why
elon's getting all [__] bent out of
shape
here that's why he's all [__]
up because he clearly does not
understand that here's an image um of
the situation that I'm talking about at
Walmart um you know this could
be interpreted several different ways
but here you
go can you imagine if you now the the
salute here is a little wrong I don't
know if the rat did the U did the AI not
let us let us do a
um a grass the grass is this High salute
you know what I mean the grass is this
high this is more like a Josh Holly Nazi
type salute that's why I was really
disappointed in Josh Ali rat I was
really disappointed in him you know the
famous picture on January 6 where he's
pumping his fist he really needed to get
his his elbow straight right and his
fingers out there like like Hitler and
the SS would be really disappointed in
Josh hly don't you think I mean I think
so but thanks for the image here of the
uh the S the SS workers at
Walmart Walmart could probably sue me
for that couldn't they I don't know [__]
I don't know for postulating that they
that people show up and [__] Nazi
uniforms what what do you want from
me I'm just trying to put it in a way
that people understand this [__] because
some people can walk and chew gum at the
same time but some people need to be put
it in a certain way so they can walk and
chew gum at the same time makes it a lot
easier when you show people what's
important all right let's go to this
[__] video of
Elon using his First Amendment right to
destroy Twitter I mean absolutely
destroyed now a lot of these moments are
[__] hilarious okay I'm not gonna lie
they're [__] just funny as [__] but
this this video here that I'm gonna show
you of a Jonathan Ross sorin
Swan he confused oh my God I'm gonna
show you that one too I'm just kidding
it's it's Andrew Ros sorin the best part
watch this watch this this is the best
part Elon sitting up on stage I'm going
to show you the video where he confuses
him this is the guy interviewing him
right okay it's called the deal book
Summit and it's sponsored by the New
York Times now elon's sitting in the
chair across from the little water here
where Andrew Ros sorin his name his
[__] name is written behind Elon
folks and he calls him Jonathan because
he's confusing confuses Andrew Ron Orin
with Jonathan
Swan we'll get to that part though this
is the main meat of how Elon just
destroyed Twitter with his first
amendment
right his freedom of speech destroyed
Twitter folks freedom of speech did not
make Twitter
better it destroyed
Twitter because these freedom of speech
absolutist which is [__] wild and
crazy there is no absolute freedom of
speech it does not
exist it's not a thing even our Supreme
Court has said there is no absolute
freedom of speech there is consequences
and sometimes there is consequences that
go against freedom of speech but let's
watch here as Elon Musk uses his freedom
of speech to destroy Twitter this is
great obviously you know that there's a
public perception that and and you're
clarifying this
now um but there's a public perception
that that was part of a apology tour if
you will that this had been said online
there was all of the criticism there was
advertisers leaving we talked to Bob IG
stop you hope don't advertise okay so
there's how it starts right and it's not
going so well because Andrew Ross Orin
is trying to ask him and I want to show
you this uh behind Elon Musk Elon must
name tag is behind him right so Elon
could make sure he knew his name that
way he knows he's not Tony Stark okay
I'm just
saying Tony Stark he is not he is Elon
Musk and to some degree I think this guy
has believed this
[__] kind of this Tony Stark type
[__] where he thinks he's this fictional
character because people have fed him
full of this [__] that sometime
somehow he's like the most famous person
in the world and he's the richest he's
most powerful and he's the smartest
person he I mean look at him he looks
like [__] look at this I don't know what
kind of work this guy's had done lately
but [__] me this is like this is like
late 90s Michael Jackson style looking
like [__] you know what I mean where
he's all [__] up he looks like he's
been I don't know if he's been bleaching
his skin or what his hair you know this
guy's had hair plugs he's had all kinds
of gender reconfirming
surgery Elon Musk you know even though
he's against gender reconfirming surgery
for other people he loves it and he
clearly has had plenty of it he needs to
get his [__] ears done though you
know how old men men get old and they
get these big [__] ears you know I'm
talking about you get these big [__]
ears their ears get huge because like
your ears and your your ears don't stop
growing so they turn into like Dumbo
looking [__] you know what I
mean oh yeah [__] you have you have you
have old men with the ear loes on the
size of king-sized mattresses you know
what I'm talking about Elon you should
really focus on getting your ears done
next that would be my suggestion or do
something you know about this body of
yours looks like a melted puddle of ice
cream I mean if you're going to spend
your money on this type of [__] spend it
on where it matters I'm just saying that
your face is all [__] up stop spending
money on your face um anyways where was
I at oh yes oh yes I was talking about I
was talking about how Elon Musk was
saying all kinds of anti-Semitic [__] on
his Twitter account not that he's
allowing anti-i Semitic statements and
Nazi statements and Nazis to run
and run rampid on Twitter he he was
posting anti-semitic [__] even even
going as far as trying to [__] give
some kind of credence to the pizza gate
thing and I know that pissed a lot of
people off a lot of people were upset
that Elon was putting the pizz gate
story back into the ether uh I actually
think that's a good thing yes I said it
I think it's a good thing this just
proves how [__] wildly [__] crazy
the these people
are on the right and we're supposed to
act like they're some kind of sane
[__] and they're
not because the ones that are supposed
to be reasonable when Elon posted the
pizzagate stuff they're like oh maybe
there's something to it they're not
reasonable these aren't serious [__]
people this is not a serious [__]
person here this guy believes he's some
kind of fictional Tony Stark type
character he's been convinced of his own
book bull [__] but let's continue here
let's continue watching burn down any
chance he has to save
Twitter you don't want them to adverti
no what do you
mean if somebody's going to try to
Blackmail me with advertising blackmail
me with money go [__]
yourself but go [__]
yourself exactly so he goes balls deep
into it right and and Andrew Ross sorin
or Jonathan as Elon thinks he is
Jonathan Swan that's who Elon thinks he
is what crazy [__] I mean I I'm thinking
that's who he thinks he is well here let
me show you let me show you here let's
see here is um here's some pictures of
um Jonathan Swan and Andrew rth sorin
here's Jonathan Swan and the Trump
interview and these are the two
guys I mean they they you know they kind
of have similar Fe they obviously don't
look alike they they have two different
accents too I mean if you know anything
but I think he was
confusing him with Jonathan Swan and
we'll get back to that clip
later um but the thing is that Andrew
rth sorin invoked Bob ier and the reason
why Jonathan Swan invoked Bob Iger
here Jonathan Swan Andrew rossin Jesus
Christ even I'm confused now
because I'm trying to keep that story
line in my head because that's hilarious
that clip is funny you're G to love this
clip but Andre Ros sorin um invokes Bob
iger's name and the reason why he
invokes Bob iger's name is because as we
all know Bob Iger is the CEO of Disney
and Disney is a huge huge buyer of
advertising on Twitter huge like h100
million dollar I think huge a lot of
[__] money like it literally is going
to keep Elon alive and Twitter alive
right but let's keep going here let's
see what he says about Bob
clear I hope it is hey Bob if you're in
the audience hey Bob if you're in the
audience so he's basically telling Bob
Iger to go [__] himself but he goes a
step further here watch this well well
let me ask you
then that's how I feel don't
advertise how do you think then about
the economics of of x if if if if part
of the underlying model at least today
and maybe it needs to shift maybe the
answer is it needs to shift away from
advertising um if if you believe that
this is the one part of your business
where you will be beholden to those who
uh have this
view what you do f y g
FY go [__] yourself gfy he says so not
only does he say it out loud then he
tells Bob to go [__] himself he doubles
down on it and he triples down on it
before he realizes that he [__] up
because there is a moment that the light
bulb goes off on in elon's head and
Andrew Ross s sorin turns it on for him
watch
this I I understand but there's a
reality
too
right yes no no
right here and she's got to sell
advertis absolutely he says your [__]
employee here who's in charge of keeping
Twitter live to sell advertising is
sitting right here and you're telling
all her potential clients to go [__]
themselves and there's a reality here
that she she has to keep your [__]
company going and the light bulb goes
off on his head going oh [__] the the
speech I say the [__] I say has
consequences son of a [__] and it goes
off in his head
Andrew Andrew Ros sorin turns on the
light
switch of reality and even says that
that there's a reality to it watch this
so um no no to totally so so no actually
what do advertising boycott is is is
gonna do it's GNA kill the
company and there you have it what this
advertising boycott is going to do is
going to kill the company and what Elon
Musk is saying in that moment is yes
there is a reality the company is [__]
but it's not my fault I'm the victim
here
see I'm the victim here I'm the one who
who couldn't [__] stop tweeting memes
and I'm the one who's a [__] baby
Manchild and couldn't just hand over the
company to someone who could run it
properly I'm the one who couldn't go
[__]
myself Elon Elon Elon
go [__] yourself okay go [__] off dude
it's it will be the best thing that ever
[__] happen to you is if you just
[__] off just [__] off just go [__] off
somewhere sell
Twitter sell
Twitter and go [__] off go be rich sell
[__] Tesla sell SpaceX sell all your
[__] and go [__] off
somewhere go [__] off take your own
[__]
advice take your own [__]
advice crying and whining who does this
remind you of who does this remind you
of when they put themselves in a
situation and they're paint themselves
into a corner and then they say oh my
God you all
just you made me paint myself into a
corner how dare you how dare you paint
me make me paint myself into a
corner every [__]
time every [__] time these [__]
right-wing real redpilled incels these
maanga Trump Elon [__]
shills step on
rakes
and you think that but and the whole
world will know that those advertisers
killed company and we will document it
in great detail oh yeah the whole world
the whole world will be on my side
there'll be so many people on my side
because so many people are victims like
me and they believe that I'm a
victim how in the [__] do you look up to
this [__] how in the [__] does anyone
think that this is [__] toughness
that this is [__] strength are you
[__] me get the [__] out of here
with this and some people are saying
that I'm
whining I'm whining the [__] listen I
got plenty of [__] to whine about folks
I got plenty of [__] to whine
about I got plenty of it you got plenty
of [__] to whine about too I'm sure we
all got [__] problems [__] I can sit
here and talking to you about how this
show has [__] made me broke and how
just sitting here and and doing this
show is is not doing my [__]
financial future any kind of good but I
think it does good for the country I
could sit and whine about that all
[__] day
long but I got better [__] to point out
I got better [__] to do like this guy
[__]
whining and destroying people's minds
this guy's destroying people's minds
folks and that's what he's saying In
This Moment he's like all these people
who sent for me they're going to
document it and there Matt taibe oh you
should see Matt taii is gonna do so many
threads about this on Twitter and Matt
Ty's gonna cry one and all the other
people who who who I promised a bunch of
money to if they just tweeted Nazi stuff
that they get advertising dollars
they're gonna be mad too they're gonna
be mad at you get the [__] out of
here how does anyone think that this is
strength this is the is the
essential example of [__]
weakness this is not [__]
strength just because you tell someone
to go [__] themselves doesn't make you
tough doesn't make you tough
Elon doesn't make you
tough see we get to punch up to you
dummy you're the richest man the
smartest man in the world we get to
punch up to you we get to speak truth to
power to
you you are not the victim here my
friend you are not the
victim and playing victim makes it even
more obvious that you're not the
victim but there are those advertisers I
imagine are going to say they're going
to say we can kill the company oh yeah
they're going to say tell to tell to
Earth what they're going to say they're
going to say Elon that you killed the
company because you said these things
and that they were inappropriate things
and they didn't feel comfortable on the
platform right that's that's what're say
and let's see how Earth responds to that
let's see how Earth responds to that
let's see how Earth responds to
that oh my
god let's see how Earth
dude
dude get your [__] head checked
man get your [__] head checked yeah
Noah Noah says it right here Ur says go
[__]
yourself that's what ER says go [__]
yourself buddy go [__] off somewhere
okay Jesus Christ are you kidding me how
is Earth going to respond oh my God this
guy he does not live in the same reality
that we live in he does not live in the
same
reality that we all
experience and that is why these incels
love him is because he lives on a
different [__]
planet he lives on the different Earth
than us that's why he says how Earth is
going to respond what the [__] is he
talking about
Earth Earth Earth oh like he's some kind
of powerful being
like he's Tony Stark or some [__] dude
this is not a Marvel movie this is real
[__]
life what a
dingus I'm happy for him though I really
am I'm happy for Elon oh [__] nothing
can please me
more but Jonathan on the other hand he
wasn't happy about
this so I will certainly not Pander and
jonan like the only reason I'm here is
because you
friend like what was my speaking
fee oh my God he calls in Jonathan he
thinks he's Jonathan swan look at this
look he thinks he's Jonathan Swan this
this is Jonathan Swan this is Andrew
Ross sorin this is Jonathan Swan this oh
now that that's I don't is that is that
real or is that AI I think he is AI
let me let me go back to the uh the
comparison picture here here it is sorry
about that here's here's Andrew Ross
sorin here's Jonathan Swan here's Andrew
Ross sorin here's Jonathan Swan that's
who I think he's confusing with don't
you don't you think that like that
that's what I that's what I'm thinking
when I saw this but but I don't know you
you decide let's back it up let's watch
it and let's watch how Jonathan or
Andrew responds is great
so I will certainly not p and Jonathan
like the only reason I'm here because
you a friend Jonathan is a friend of his
what was my speaking fee you you're not
making any first of all I'm Andrew but
yeah sorry it's okay [__] hang on hang
on hang on I don't even end up on screen
look at this [__] I'm
worthless the only reason I'm here is
because you are a
friend like what was my speaking fee you
you're
of all I'm
Andrew of all we've known each for very
long we've known each other for a very
long
time the only reason now I tell you I
tell you what they're gonna do right
they're gonna be like oh elon's so smart
he he even he even mocked Andrew by
calling him Jonathan oh he did that on
purpose that was
purposeful he did that on purpose
okay
okay brilliant brilliant a brilliant
mind here this guy he is by calling
Andrew rossor
and
Jonathan holy
[__] if you're not excited now Twitter's
not going to go anywhere folks I know
some people think that Twitter's going
to crash and burn but here's the thing
you gotta understand who actually owns
Twitter it's not it's not
Elon let me give you a little hint
here you got a mortgage out there
probably or you've had a mortgage before
or you know how mortgages work
essentially try not paying your mortgage
payment for two or three months and see
if you can find out who owns your house
right you follow me on that you got a
mortgage you're paying your mortgage
every month to the bank okay the person
who loaned you the
money and let's say you stop making
those payments how long before you find
out that you don't actually own your
house how long how long you think what
it take you four months five months
something like
that Elon doesn't own Twitter
folks Elon has a
mortgage on Twitter that Cynthia is all
over it Saudi Arabia owns Twitter
Saudis own the American company Twitter
because elon's in Hawk to them for the
mortgage for
it and I'm I'm not
saying that I know something you don't
know because I I I'm just guessing here
this is just my guess this is me going
off of what Saudis probably do to people
who owe them a [__] sh [__] ton of
money right and they can't pay them what
do you think the Saudis are going to do
to someone who owes them billions tens
of billions of
dollars and can't pay that [__]
back what do you
think what do you think they're going to
do
that I think I think they're gonna [__]
them off
somewhere
yep I think they're gonna [__] them off
some
Elon you're in hot trouble my friend and
Earth says Earth says go [__] yourself
please someone rat put this in the memes
get this on Discord this is the greatest
one I think we've had in a long time
Earth tells Elon to go [__] yourself
cause Elon you can [__]
off but you don't [__] off don't [__]
off don't go [__] yourself the audience
don't go [__] yourself we'll be right
back right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast I've always wanted to learn a
new language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a Maga Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacist the first lesson began
with learning simple phrases and soon I
was putting those words and phrases into
a conversation each lesson takes about
10 to 15 minutes to complete and they're
all really different which keeps things
interesting the app is really smart it
actually keeps track of the words that
I'm struggling with I chose Babel magga
Edition because it's created by smart
white people like me and now I can't
wait to expl explore meet new friends
and use my new magga skills with my
in-laws all lives
matter jumping back into it this is the
Tony Michaels
podcast earthon Earth the Elon don't
[__] yourself don't [__]
[Music]
yourself best audience in the world you
guys have the best ideas in the chat as
always as always all right let me show
you this um this clip of George
Santos excuse me I'm still having
coughing fits so if you see me mute and
cough it's I'm still trying to get over
this
[__] yesterday I felt much better um
today this morning I felt much better
but I I didn't
take my normal medicine today because I
thought I could lay off today um and I I
can't I shouldn't have I should have
taken the the medicine that helps me not
cough but it is what it is Big Steph
asked me Tony did you drink last night
[__] yeah I
did Hells yeah I did did you guys buy
shots last night for me let's go find
out let's go find out I did some shots
last night I had a margarita
too had a a pregame Margarita and then
went and had some
shots ah there's some people buying
merch holy moly um but I don't think I
got any shots last
night
God damn it I totally should have took
the the medicine I'll do it tomorrow
tomorrow's Friday I'll take the [__]
tomorrow and tomorrow's
um I'm
sorry Courtney asked karaoke yes I sang
a few songs but I had to sing low songs
I couldn't get into my higher
range with the coughing and the drainage
and all that [__] Patty says take your m
yeah well it's not like prescri it's
just like
Mucinex so I have really bad sinuses if
yall want to know like this kind of [__]
if you want to know the the beef on why
I've been sick I had a sinus infection
and I take musx to drain the
[__] and it's the drainage that kills me
and it you know settles in your chest it
settles in your lungs and you get to
coughing and I'm trying to take care of
myself I've been resting a lot I've been
sleeping a lot I'm still doing my my
thing
right but I'm trying to rest so
that I can get feeling better I gotta
have my my voice uh apparently there's
some breaking news Trump is gagged again
now this isn't surprising I think he's
supposed to testify today now let's see
if we can Lisa Ruben has the story here
H let me pull it up on the screen here
is um here's the breaking news
new uh Forge a panel of appell at judges
have denied Trump's motion for a
long-term stay of gag orders so looks
like those gag orders are GNA be back on
so he's gagged
again you rat bastard rat back there
with the
with the sound
effects he's got me he's got me even
when I'm trying not to
cough oh [__] oh [__] let's see what
else do we got
here oh
man oh so let me go to the George Santos
clip and let me show you why you folks
really need to hold off on um saying
[__] that
just doesn't make any sense and you
really don't want them to turn around
and use it on you because here's what
happens now a lot of people are going to
throw this back and say but Tony but
Tony this and Tony that and Jamal Bowman
this I like Jamal
Bowman I don't want Jamal Bowman to be
expelled no no that's not what I want I
don't think he I don't think what he did
is expellable if you want to know the
honest truth it might it might uh
justify some sort of
Ethics uh hearing and ethics invest
tigation I mean he pled guilty to a
misdemeanor to pulling a fire alarm
that's the [__] truth whether you
like it or
not no matter what you think about Jamal
Bowman he did
lie to you Jamal Bowman
did he said it was an accident and then
he played to a
misdemeanor um someone says Tony stop
with the Jamal [__] dude what does what
does that mean stop with the Jamal [__]
what what do you mean you want me to you
want me to to ignore what is the
truth that's that's the pro that's what
I keep saying is the problem we can't
ignore the it's okay for us to know the
truth it's
okay it's okay to know that Joe Biden's
old like he's old he's 81 he's old
that's okay it's all right we don't have
to we don't have to act like something
isn't when it is or it is when it isn't
we don't have to do that [__] we don't
have to be offended by everything we
don't we
don't I mean you can be offended but we
as a collective do not have to get
offended by every little thing we as a
collective do not have to [__] go on
these tie raids about this stupid [__]
that doesn't matter we don't have to do
that we don't so I mean I I I'm glad
you're here and I'm glad you're
dissenting right but listen Jamal Bowman
lied to you whether you like it to hear
that way or not I like Jamal
Bowman I like Jamal Bowman that is my
opinion uh thn's right um you can choose
to not have an opinion it's always on
the table Yeah that's the truth you can
choose not to have an opinion on
something the problem is is that
Democrats Republicans are setting
motions to expel George Santos right
this is real [__] that's happening in
the house and the [__] that George
Santos did has real world consequences
not just for his seat of
Congress but for him as a as a person
walking around with freedom when you
steal money from people when you commit
fraud and you
lie especially when it's campaign money
and [__] and you're spending it and
they've got record of it it's going to
come back to
you it really is it's going to come back
to haunt
you but I mean if if if I'm sitting here
and I'm gonna and I'm gonna tell you the
story about George Santos being expelled
today and not tell you about this part
of the story then I'm not telling you
the story I'm misleading
you so if if you if if and again I I
understand I understand I understand
the sentiment of Jamal Bowman not
wanting to mention that not wanting to
bring that
up but by ex trying to expel George
Santos you're bringing it up you're
bringing it up it's the same thing I
keep saying about this 14th Amendment
[__] you people are bringing up stuff
that you don't want to bring up by doing
that
[__] that's what you're doing you're
creating
narratives because you don't [__]
think about what the hell is happening
and what the hell you're offended by
before you don't think two steps
ahead and a lot of times it's it's not
because you the
audience it's as a collective right as a
collective we get on social media and we
get mad about this we get mad about that
we get mad about this we get mad about
that uh I seen um um a lot of people mad
about this little boy at the Chiefs game
who had half his face painted black and
half his face painted red I didn't have
an opinion on it because I thought it
was a kid at a game painting his face
for a game and he was dressed up because
his Chiefs fans now I live in Chiefs
country I've been to a lot of chiefs
games so I understand kind of like that
that thing but a lot of people thought
the kid was wearing blackace I didn't
see it that way and I know a lot of
people were offended by it and that's
their that's their right to be offended
but as a
collective as a collective we're going
to do this thing because I don't know if
you know this but apparently the kid's
grandfather was actually a
native and he was of a certain tribe and
like it really backfired on people who
were offended by it and who wanted to
make a big deal out of it it's a kid
with face paint at a football
game and I get that you were offended
maybe you should you have the right to
be offended if you you want to be
offended that's that's your right it's
your
Liberty that's what I'm advocating for
is your Liberty to
descent but when you dissent in a
group and you advocate for descent that
will backfire on you you are living with
consequences of your freedom of
speech that's you living with
consequences of your freedom of speech
and this clip here of George Santos
saying what he's saying about Jamal mman
this is a consequence of people using
their freedom of speech to call for his
Expo expulsion let's talk about uh let's
talk about consistency we have a member
of Congress that earlier this year took
a plea deal to obstructing a
congressional hearing that's not the
plea deal he took right I'm kidding he
took a plea deal for pulling a fire
alarm a fire alarm which obstructed and
delayed an official hearing and
proceeding on the house floor now has
had that been any other person had it
been one of the members of the media had
it been a republican member of Congress
we all know that that person would have
been file would have been charged with
obstructing a congressional hearing now
this is a dumb
argument it's really
stupid to think that Jamal mman is
somehow a January
sixer that he was trying to obstruct
official proceeding in a different
[__] building this is ridiculous it's
boneheaded at best okay it's
boneheaded the argument that he's making
the problem is is that we the collective
have put ourselves in a situation where
George Santos can say this [__] and a
lot of people go you know
what
whoa again you think it how you want to
think it you offend it how you want to
offend it but your speech and our
Collective speech and our Collective
narrative has a [__] consequence it's
certainly has a [__] consequence
folks that's what I keep telling you
that's what I keep yelling and screaming
that's what I keep telling you about the
14th Amendment thing because the
collective the
collective
consequence of the 14th Amendment [__]
is that people are going to get
discouraged and it's going to disengage
people and if people disengage in our
democracy and they disengage in the
ballot Trump has a chance to
win you got it you follow you see what
I'm saying you may not think it you may
not believe me you may say I'm wildly
out of Step I'm crazy I'm not I'm not
[__]
crazy right
um de DEA I don't I don't know if this
initials or not on YouTube says he's
such a drama queen oh
yeah no doubt George Santos is a drama
queen and this is a dumb stupid [__]
argument the problem is is he gets to
make the
argument now honestly if George Santos
had a half a brain he would say [__] and
make this argument and it would stick he
it's not gonna stick though it's not
gonna stick because George Santos is a
dumb fck
right but the reason why this narrative
starts to spin
now because I'm telling you anyone who
wants to defend George Santos is now
going to use this [__] they're going to
use it they're going to use
it rather you like it or not whether
it's stupid or
not whether it's ridiculous and it's a
invalid argument or
not and they're going to start to form a
narrative and the narrative is gon to
build and build and build and build when
all you had to do was just go with the
narrative that I said let George Santos
stay in congress let's Point him out
that hey he is a republican like he's
the he's he is the spitting image of a
republican a crooked [__] lion piece
of
trash and if you expel George Santos you
have to expel all
Republicans there is a way to form
narrative there's a way to to form
thought there's a way to be
offended if you want as a collective
that doesn't backfire on you
so many times I see this stupid [__]
from the left it's this stupid [__] I
talked about it yesterday with this
[__] Pro Palestinian protest I'm not
saying those people don't have a right
and they don't have a point the
Palestinian people deserve Liberty they
deserve freedom for crying out [__]
loud they human beings godamn
it and that's the principle that I hold
is that every human being has the right
to Liberty I don't give a [__] where
you're from your religion what gender
you are what sex how old you are I don't
give a [__] I don't care what your
beliefs are you deserve
Liberty there something a human right
that you should be given is
liberty and when we sacrifice that stuff
for dumb stupid narratives dumb stupid
narratives are going to
build and they're going to build against
us so we got to keep our [__] heads
on straight this is so dumb and
ridiculous that we do this to ourselves
I pointed it out when they started the
stupid thing about cameras in courtrooms
you remember that [__] they started to
build that stupid [__]
narrative that was a dumb [__]
narrative to build and I don't know if
I'm the one that got out in front of it
and smashed it or not but I was the one
speaking out against it
immediately and I was speaking out
against people that you
like the
audience because they were saying [__]
you wanted to hear which is going to
backfire badly it's going to
backfire
backfire we can't let our own narratives
backfire on us can
we uh San cat says uh Santos needs to
know when learn to when to shut up I
mean I actually think he should keep
talking the more people like Santos talk
the worse it gets for them I mean
honestly the worse it gets for them I
mean basically George Santos saying here
is I want to expel Jamal
Bowman because he committed misdemeanors
I committed felonies and I want to expel
him because he commit a instument so we
should expel you too like the narrative
is dumb it's dumb it's stupid but that's
the point that was jimie raskins point
if you remember on the floor of the
house when he gave his reason why he
voted not to expel George Santos I don't
know if you guys remember that little
speech that jam Askin and the reason why
Jam Askin uh voted not to expel
him and it was principled and I
appreciate that Jamie Rasin did what he
did because it was principled in the
foundation of
democracy and
Justice and not a two-tier justice
system are trying to not have some sort
of two-tier justice
system so I I I appreciate
that will George Santos be expelled I
don't know I don't know I
mean Earth is going to expel him Earth
is
gonna Earth is going to tell George
Santos hey Georgie Porgy go [__]
yourself go [__] yourself that's what
Earth's going to tell George
Santos because George Santos is done
rather rather they expel him or not he's
not going to be a congressman he can't
rerun he can't he can't get any money
because he stole all the people who gave
him money so they can't they're not
gonna No One's Gonna give him money to
run
now dumb
[__] wh why why waste any more breath or
any more motions or any more time on
George Santos than you have to let him
The Rake that they step on to be quite
honest let George Santos be the rake
that they step
on speaking of rakes to step on um and I
want to show you this and I don't
normally show clips of Joe Biden but um
this clip was put together by my friend
uh Christopher web and I thought it was
a very good cut um it shows Lauren
bobert you know that Dum Dum oh hand job
Lauren
I think it's hand jobs ain't that what
it is in the Beetle Juice thing isn't
that what she was doing I don't
know I I don't decide these things don't
get after me because [__] Lauren
bobert likes to give hand jobs inside of
a theater this is not my problem this is
not my fault but I have to point out
this [__] that she
does I'm actually glad that that [__]
Lauren Boer gives handies in a theater
so I can talk about it I'm I'm gonna be
honest with you I like that I like that
about Lauren bber I'm not gonna lie I
like that I like that she gives hand
jobs in Beetlejuice so that we can talk
about
it I
mean government's [__] boring folks
it's boring do you know how hard it's
gonna be when we get back to
normal how hard it's GNA be for me to do
this show and keep you guys entertained
when there's not Congress women giv hand
jobs in a beetle juu uh music somewhere
in
Colorado it's going to be really really
[__] tough but we're going to try to
do it we're going to try to do it but
here is Lauren bber now this top uh clip
is from a while back this is from her
talking about the inflation reduction
Act and the infrastructure law and how
she's really pissed off about the money
that's going to go to her District but
watch how Joe Biden responds can you see
how it started and how it begins watch
this we are sacrificing you are sacrif
icing American families at the altar of
climate change it does the exact
opposite of what Americans need right
now this is just another con game by the
Democrats calling something one
thing this is making the
IRS hased the Pentagon the state
gentoman is no longer recognized the
gentleman from Missouri reserves
the Mr
Speaker how much time do you need the
gentlewoman is no longer recognized your
time is insired I just wish she had as
much enthusiasm about this about making
sure Americans don't get funding um and
as much enthusiasm she has about giving
handies in the theater I wish she just
had that enthusiasm about defending
middle class Americans that would be
nice and middle class American jobs like
Joe Biden defends them here we're
invested in America we're investing in
Americans and it's working since I took
office my investing America agenda has
led to manufacturing boom has attracted
over $600 billion $600 billion in
private investment from private
companies in America and around the
world manufacturing and industries of
the future when I took office we set a
goal to produce 100% carbon free
electricity by
2035 because of my commitment to clean
energy Future made in America clean
energy companies started investing here
here in Colorado here in Colorado CS
wind a Korean company makes towers and
wind turbines I know you all know people
seeing this on television may not be
certain they used to make all their wind
towers abroad then they decided to make
them here in America as well and today
CS wind factory in Colorado is the
largest wind Tower manufacturer in the
entire world the entire world so there
you have
it she was advoc for the opposite
folks she was advocating against
American jobs she was advocating for
that Korean company to keep those jobs
overseas that's what she was advocating
for and I keep telling you this and I
know
sometimes sometimes I don't do the best
job at pointing
out every single little thing that Joe
Biden's doing right because he's doing
so many of them um but I always tell you
that Joe Biden when we look back in
history and even now he is the
most pro-american worker president that
we've had in our modern time the most
pro-american worker president that we
have had I believe that everything and
every decision Joe Biden makes domestic
economic policy that he makes his first
thought in his mind is how will this
affect the American
worker it's pretty [__] easy and it's
pretty easy to see that that that's what
his main goal is now he's not always
gonna be right he's not going to get
this right every single time economics
is a [__] weird thing right because
there's always always unintended
consequences when you do something just
like with your freedom of speech and
Elon telling Earth Earth to telling [__]
off to Elon there's always unintended
con consequences right when you do
something sometimes there's consequences
that you're not going to see you're
not you're not going to see it right
away it may take a while for you to
realize those unintended consequences
sometimes those consequences are
good and they turn out for the best
sometimes they're bad and they turn out
to not be the best but in this situation
where Lauren bobbert decided to vote
against money going to
coloradans so that they could open up
factories there to have jobs good paying
jobs she voted no she didn't want it not
only did she not vote no she was not
following house rules to interrupt a
debate about it let's finish with dark
Brandon here with over 870 employees
it's simple as I've said for a long time
when I think climate and I mean it
sincerely I think jobs jobs that's a
climate's about not only saving lives
and saving the environment but jobs oh
he thinks jobs just what I
said this isn't I mean I know I know a
lot of people want to make [__]
complicated like they really do they
want to make stuff all kinds of
complicated and [__] but the idea that
in in Colorado CS wind the world's
largest wind Tower manufacturer now in
it's $200
million in pleo Colorado the facility
expansion okay and it's because the of
the infrastructure Act
Lauren bber not only voted against it
Chris Webb points
out she called it
garbage she called it
garbage she didn't want $200 million
going to pleo Colorado she thinks that's
garbage for her constituents to benefit
from a $200 million
investment and the reason why is because
she's a [__] bonehead and she
believes lies the climate change ain't
real climate change ain't real and
you're hearing what Joe Biden's saying I
don't hear climate change or climate and
think the Earth's burning I think how
can we fix this problem with
jobs [__]
man and you're worried about this guy's
age Lauren bobbert listen Joe Biden is a
grandpa right he looks like a [__]
Grandpa he's the age of a [__]
Grandpa right Joe Biden's old he's 81
he's a grandpa so is Lauren
bobert Lauren bobert is a grandma okay
she's granny handy if you want to give
her a handle granny
handy she's a grandma she's not old
she's younger than me
[__] she's a grandma and she's
[__] younger than me
me what the [__] does age got to do with
it huh ask yourself what the [__] does
age got to do with it you stupid
[__] yes he's a grandpa yes he's
old yep sure is but the guy gets up
every morning and he thinks about the
American people and he sets policy based
on those thoughts about the American
people first
right hey there you go there's you
[__] slogan there's you some
narrative America people first right
American people first why
not what the [__] does his age got to do
with
it because here you have you have Lauren
bobert who's a granny let me let me let
me U I'm gonna mute this hang on a
second we are sacrificing here's here's
here's oh GR granny handy here's granny
handy here she's younger than I am she's
a grandma she's a granny she loves give
handies Granny
handy and she hates American jobs she
thinks they're garbage especially $200
million worth American jobs in her
District of pleo
Colorado
now here's Joe Biden here's Grandpa
Biden
Papa
Biden yeah he's a little older than her
and he doesn't hand out he doesn't hand
out he doesn't hand out hand jobs he's
focused on jobs not hand jobs okay a
little different kind of grandparent
right when your grandpa's focused on
jobs and your grandma's focused on hand
jobs little different kind of
grandparent there
probably
I don't know maybe you could use this
when someone's like J bad's old he's
he's too
old he's too old to realize that
Americans want decent [__] wages that
Americans don't want to go broke because
of medical
bill he's too dumb to make sure the set
policy to put the American worker
first when all the time granny handy
over here who ain't even 40 yet
is calling those policies that put
American workers first
garbage well I can tell you what I think
is garbage and it's Lauren bobert oh I'm
not off I'm not off the granny handy
train
yet let's see if this hand job backfire
on backfires on her I don't know maybe
the money shot oh there's a money shot
here watch you all are allowing
delinquent employees employes to sit on
their sofas at home instead of actually
getting to work and doing their jobs all
right here's someone who continues to go
to Washington DC knows nothing about
being a congress
person continues to not know
how floor procedure Works she can't
spend 15 minutes to get off her [__]
couch giving hand jobs at theaters to
understand how procedure
works but she's going to
lecture a government official about
government employees sitting on the
couch not doing their [__] job this
feels like it's gonna blow up in her
face
watch this is absolutely
unacceptable so our employees are
working whether they are in the office
or at home and they are are you
monitoring the work that they are doing
from home on a regular basis yes we are
every every employee do you have do you
have the numbers of the hours that are
submitted are are you counting how many
times they're logging into their
computers and responding to case workk
so okay so here's the thing here's how
dumb she is and here's how stupid
Republicans are all
right so one of her staffers brought her
this
information this is what
happened this is what happened some dumb
[__] some
right-winger saw something on Twitter
woo
and saw that there's government workers
who work from home and they were like
those lazy liberal pieces of [__] as if
government workers have to be liberal
right that's the dumbest [__] I've ever
heard of in my life just because you're
a government worker and you're a public
servant and you're a civil servant and
you're a bureaucrat does not mean you're
a [__] liberal now most the time
bureaucrats see how government works and
they understand how government works
because they are part of of it so they
tend to have liberal ideas because I
don't know they just [__] rub their
brain cells together and use thoughts
and logical thinking and they use the
rationale to determine that it's
probably liberal government that works
better than conservative government
that's probably what it is but you know
that's neither here nor there but there
are plenty plenty trust me there are
plenty of [__] bureaucrats out there
plenty of government workers who are
[__] dumbass Republicans and they're
stupid [__] conservatives and they
have really stupid about how government
shouldn't shouldn't work it is a thing
it happens okay don't think that it
doesn't but you can tell here that
someone has given her this information
that there's lazy government workers
sitting on their couches at home working
from
home okay oh my
God handma here everyone's calling her
handma
handma oh my
God
oh my God Hand ma are you serious you
[__] are the funniest sons of
[__] ever
handma goddamn okay handma here got
brought a piece of information from some
dumb [__] stupid staffer that she
has and they were like yeah there's lazy
government workers working from home and
what she should have done what she
should have done in that
moment was ask that stupid [__]
staffer the questions that she's asking
him like okay so uh we want to spend the
narrative that they're lazy are they
monitoring these people are they are
they tracking them like what are they
doing to make sure that they're not
being lazy that's what she should have
done before this hearing but she's doing
what she should have done that's why she
has this dumb [__] look on her face
because she
realizes that she's about to get the
money shot right she knows a money
handball knows a money shot when she
sees one right handball knows a money
shot when she sees
one and she's about to get one right
smack dab in the face watch so our
employees are subject to the same
Performance Management processes and
oversight they are whether they're
teleworking or working in an office and
we have systems in place that our
managers use to schedule assign and
track workloads and that includes
individual employee workloads in many
cases so real time understanding of what
actions are being processed at any
particular given time additionally our
employees are required to be accessible
to their supervisors clients colleagues
and external parties during work hours
fora a variety of means including
instant messaging video platforms and
telephone they are connected to the
workplace whether they are in the office
or at the home then why is the backlogs
for Social Security applicants increase
from
41,000 to 700,000 because we've been why
why why what could it be that government
isn't functioning properly what could it
possibly [__] be handma what could it
be what could it be could it be that
you're so [__] lazy that you're going
to theaters in Colorado watching beeto
juice jacking some guy off huh could
that be what it is could it be that your
[__] staff is so inep so [__]
stupid that they're not willing to go
past just the simple [__] crumb of
the fact that there's government workers
that work from home and you think
they're [__] lazy could it be that
could it be that you're so [__]
you're still [__] lazy and you don't
know how to do your [__] job is to
just get the [__] facts in front of
you so you can make a rational decision
now this guy clearly knew that this
questioning was G to come up he clearly
knew that this [__] bonehead was
gonna call government workers who work
at home lazy pieces of trash is what she
was gonna do and then what she was gonna
do is Pivot to say the reason why we
have backlogs is because these people
are lazy well listen up you [__]
idiot get your ears cleaned out hand mom
because he's about to hand you the
[__] truth been historically
underfunded for a number of years now I
wonder who underfunded you're funded at
the Nancy Peli levels at the Democrat
levels we just continued that same
funding oh my God oh my God Democrats
overfund government they overfund
government they overfund government we
want to defund government well what
happens when you defund government you
stupid [__] listen so I would say at
pandemic level spending so I would say
we'd have an increase of over 8 million
beneficiaries over the last 10 years at
the same time we experienced our lowest
Work Staffing levels at the end of fy22
that's a math problem I mean that is a
problem if you have those workloads you
know increasing and you don't have the
staff to take care of those workloads
you're gonna have the backlogs that
you're talking about representative
well listen to this one listen to this
right here watch the listen to what the
problem is for for him continued that
same funding so I would say at pandemic
level spending it is so say we'd have an
increase of over 8 million beneficiaries
over the last 10 years at the same time
we experienced our lowest Work Staffing
levels at the end of fy22 that's a math
problem I mean that is a problem if you
have those workloads you know increasing
and you don't have the staff to take
care of those workloads you're going to
have the backlogs that you're talking
about representative well I would love
to
see I love I would love to see the
numbers on that and and maybe I should
have looked those [__] numbers up
used and US my brain
cells if I can do math and maybe if my
staff was halfway decent
smart may maybe maybe just
maybe may maybe just
maybe I could not do M
momic it's what I've been telling you
you for a long time this is the reason
why these people suck and it sucks to
suck because they're not serious they're
not
serious granny handy granny handy here
granny handy is not serious okay I mean
she's serious about hand jobs in
theaters okay but government government
handb handb wants nothing to do with
government nothing to do with knowing
how government
works not a goddamn thing
and this is why I continue to tell you
this [__] that we have to elect serious
people serious [__] is what we
got to have because if you have someone
so unserious as handball Lauren bobert
in Congress you get you get
[__] you you get unserious [__]
results because they get unserious staff
people they [__] suck they [__]
suck and it's sucks to suck now is this
good for us long term yes it is good for
us long term to watch Lauren bobert who
is who only won by less than 500 votes
folks 500 votes these two clips that I
just showed should be enough for for 800
people out there in her District in
Colorado go [__] that dumb [__] I'm
voting for Adam I'm voote for the other
guy voting against her there is that
those two clips should turn a thousand
people to either not
vote or vote against
her because she's such a dumb [__] the
problem is is are we going are we gonna
be in a situation where we can get the
the handb tail as lfg lfg here on
YouTube calls it Han maal Han's tail and
Gabe Sanchez is going to love this Gabe
Sanchez I know he's going to do what was
that live but he might not be able to do
that you might have cancel um what was
that live now and the reason why is
because we've given Lauren bobbert a new
moniker her new mon her new moniker is
hand
ma handball handma you know like Grandma
handma oh handma well it was well here
let me show you it was it was granny
handy at first granny handy granny handy
right okay uh but then but then the chat
youan she does she you
know let's just say loves to get the old
elbow in there you know she she she
loves handouts more than she loves
government but they they they narrowed
it
down I feel like she also would love
hand like she says that she doesn't like
handouts but she loves right handouts
well we were pointing out earlier that
Joe Biden he focuses in on jobs handma
focuses in on hand jobs well she yeah
she definitely puts the hand in
[Laughter]
jobs is this what you're going to be
speaking about on what was that I mean
I'm gonna talk I'm gonna talk about that
I'm gonna talk about George Santos one
last Hail Mary oh God come on Save Jamal
Bowman I I was the audience is a little
mad at me earlier because I said this is
the reason why you know because we talk
about this like Jamie raskins reason why
he didn't vote to expel George Santos
which I thought was the best reason and
like it was the example of why we should
be be cautious of doing this stuff
because George Santos even though he
makes a really shitty argument for the
Jamal Bowman thing he's got a point it's
he he makes the shittiest argument
though he's like Jamal Bowman is an
insurrectionist and he's a gen sixer and
I'm like that's dumb like like you're
conflating those two things but he's got
a point if you're gonna expel me for
this you're you're Go I mean Jamal
Bowman pled guilty to a crime of doing a
thing so we have to be careful with this
14th talk with this expulsion talk we
got to be careful with this stuff and
the reason why is because our own stupid
logic sometimes because we don't like
someone can backfire on us right that
logic can come around and turn on us
which again I like Jamal Bowman Jamal
Bowman should not be expelled that is
the dumbest [__] ever and and Jamal
Bowman is a fighter for democracy Jamal
Bowman is a former teacher and principal
and I think there's sometimes there's no
better person who can speak for average
people and average American workers than
someone like Jamal Bowman who's been in
the workforce before before he was a
congress person ex and and I think he
should remain in Congress and I think
he's a fighter and I think he should I
respect Jamal Bowman I think what he did
was really stupid and him lying about it
was even more stupid yeah it it wasn't
it wasn't a great move right uh it it's
not a great look especially when you
have the Republican Party blowing
themselves up do not add fuel right for
the other side to say well did you see
what the other guy did right don't take
the sh out of hand and start digging
your own grave even if somebody did
something like oh they threw something
out in the trash and it missed the bin
they'd be like oh my god did you see
that like right anything you can give
them don't do it and that was something
where it's like that was a dumb dumb
dumb move I think I think when when when
he pled to the misdemeanor I think we
were texting each other I was like this
is really stupid what a dumb even before
that it was before it was when the
footage I think the longer clip got
shared yeah yeah yeah it was obvious
that he did it on purpose and like he
lied he Li and and that's that's the
biggest mistake that he made was that he
lied and and the reason why he lied is
so the internet would would defend him
which was really stupid because then
everyone came to his defense and and
because he lied because we trusted that
he would tell the truth and he didn't
which really backfired on Jamal Bowman
and now it's backfiring on Democrats
because again as much as you may not
like for me to say it George Santos even
though he makes the point really poorly
and he has a really stupid argument
about it yeah he does have a point and
the point is what jimie Rasin was trying
to tell you when he said the reason why
he wasn't voting to expel George Santos
that's the point and that's the point
that Geor Santos so poorly makes if you
want to argue something technically
George Santos and I haven't and and and
this did happen before he was in
Congress but there is
Merit in it George Santos technically
committed a crime and had a plea deal
with Brazilian authorities he has still
denied it to this day and I am and I
want to say this there is no one that
can that can deny this I literally have
the text message with George Santos
before he turned off his phone and
switch his number I have a text message
with George Santos where he literally
denies any wrongdoing in Brazil no deal
no plea nothing then for CNN and other
people even the Brazilian CNN Network to
be like there was a deal that was
reached between Brazilian authorities
and prosecutors and George Santos and
his lawyer George Santos even went on
the live the one that I broke down for
what was that in there he was like oh
that one about uh Brazil everyone's
making it up everyone's doing this no
they're not George Santos pled guilty to
stealing checks from an elder man in
Brazil years after I think it was 2008
or something like that that he stole it
after the fact he admitted CNN couldn't
even get George Santos on record for
this claim that was done George Santos
then texted me and said I didn't do it
this is all made up you I'm not a fraud
I'm not a criminal this is all you know
this is all you enjo Santos texting each
other just makes me more it makes it
more s i do I do have an inside I I do
have an inside contact someone in his
staff right now but they don't know it's
me oh okay well you know they think it's
do they think it's um some drag queen
from Brazil is that what you I don't
know if they think it's a drag queen but
they do think it's like a freedom
fighting to a bro really no [__] that's
great that's great Gabe Sanchez here's
what I want you to do I want you to send
me the link to your show that way that
way as soon as you leave here I can send
the audience over to your YouTube
channel and your Twitch Channel because
that's what's going to happen here in
just less than two minutes folks if
you're on YouTube if you're on Twitch
you're going to go to what was that live
with Gabe Sanchez and I know he's gonna
talk I know he's gonna I know he's gonna
talk about how Earth is gonna tell Elon
to go [__] himself I gotta show I gotta
show you this one we're GNA talk about
the fair market wait wa here here I
gotta show you this one last thing
before we leave here is Earth telling
Elon to go [__] go [__] yourself
beautiful go [__] yourself beautiful how
will Earth respond go watch right now
don't stay stay here but G Sanchez you
go go go on go get out get the hell out
of here go do your show everyone stick
around you're going to watch Gabe
Sanchez I know he's going to break down
the Elon thing I know that's what he's
gonna do he can't help himself he's
gonna have to break down the Elon thing
so stay here on YouTube Stay on if he
can send me the link if he sends me the
link I'll I'll be able to to send you
over there stay you're on YouTube there
it is s stay you're on YouTube Stay
you're on Twitch what was that live with
Gabe Sanchez uh coming right up after
the Tony Michaels podcast as always on
Tuesdays Wednesdays and Thursdays there
it is you guys are going to be safe same
time same place tomorrow I'm sure you'll
be mad at me big Steph says she's never
not agreed with me I wish I had that
comment here here here's that comment
here's that comment big Steph says H I
rarely disagree with Tony I have to mark
my calendar on that day mark your
calendars make sure to mark your
calendars for tomorrow same time same
place surfes up [__] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events in political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after
me [__] them [__]
them
[Music]
Murphy's muor head ass
speaking
that